- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this discussion session
of our monthly inference
colloquium series.
And for those of you who are joining us
after yesterday's lecture, as
you know, the session serves
as a forum for conversation
between our speaker
and a conversant, which
we all witnessed share
and ask questions to clarify,
to expand an extent the
remit of the lecture.
So we were really deeply
honored and it was a privilege
to listen to Eric Winsberg,
talk yesterday about causal inference
in complex nonlinear
systems of cautionary tale.
So I would like to briefly
remind you all first
that since we are recording this event,
that all participants
must mute their videos.
And as always, please
feel free to start typing
in your questions into the chat.
And we will pick them up right after Eric
and our wonderful conversant today.
Stephanie have concluded
their own sort of discussions.
So we are utterly delighted,
and it's a real honor to
have a Dr. Stephanie Harvard,
who is Michael Smith
Foundation Health Research
post-doctoral fellow at the
University of British Columbia
and the faculty of
pharmaceutical sciences there.
She received a PhD in
population and public health
in a joint program between the University
of British Columbia
and the Université Pierre
et Marie Curie in Paris.
Well, what a lovely combination
of cities Stephanie in 2017.
Her current focus research
focuses on the implications
of philosophies of values
in science, literature
for health economics, modeling
and knowledge translation.
And her postdoctoral
work current work focuses
on creating educational videos
to communicate the role of
social and ethical values in modeling
and exploring new ways of
informing health economics models
to patient and public values.
She also, co-leads a project,
a novel mechanism to
support transformative model
interrogation in patient
oriented health economics,
which is funded by the BC unit,
a health economics unit and
simulation and methods cluster.
She also happens to be the
coauthor with professor Winsberg
of the representational risk paper.
Which on his stock page, which
is on, and you can see that
that article actually on our top page,
on the inference website.
And so together, they have also coauthored
an earlier paper on public
in health modeling design.
And you might see in just a minute,
if I remind you of professor
Winsberg research interests,
and briefly tell you a little
bit about what he presented
yesterday, how apt conversant Stephanie
is for the work that
was discussed yesterday.
As you all know, professor
Winsberg is a historian
and philosopher of science,
and he has been interested
in the philosophy of climate
change, philosophy of physics,
and more generally broadly
philosophy of science.
But in particular, the role
of computer simulations
and modeling in the physical sciences.
His work in the philosophy
of climate science relates
to the application of
models and simulations
to science policy and ethics.
So his work has always
been trying to see the,
how scientific models are used
to inform policy decisions.
And of course, over the last
several months, you know,
Eric had enormous bounty in
terms of research project
falling into his lap
from multiple directions,
which is the pandemic and
the associated data, policy
responses to it, and the, just the way
in which the pandemic outcomes,
how they have unfolded.
So he talked to us about the
work that he's done using
models and methods of causal
inference in the COVID
in the unfolding COVID-19 pandemic.
And in yesterday talk
he demonstrated our blind spots
in how we leap to inferring
causality and how our directions
of inquiry and how we use
the data to inform the kinds
of judgements and value
assessments that we want
to make that in turn shape
are intended to shape public behavior.
So without much further ado, Stephanie,
I invite you to start
this discussion session.
- Okay, thank you so much, Priya.
I'm going to share my screen
and I'm just gonna double check
that I'm able to advance.
Okay, great.
Okay, so, like Priya said,
this is a conversation today
about Eric, when Winsberg
taught from yesterday,
which was called causal
inference in complex nonlinear
systems, a cautionary tale.
So for future viewers who
haven't seen that talk can go
and access that on YouTube
for the full details.
For my discussion today,
I'm going to follow
the standard two segment
format for this talk series.
So the first is the, in other words,
segment where I'm going
to give you the jest
of what I think Eric was saying yesterday.
And then I'll do the, so now what?
Segment, where I'm
going to try to draw out
some of the implications
of Eric's discussion.
This is a picture of
little red riding hood,
because I'm told that it's
a cautionary tale in itself,
roughly to the effect of
don't talk to strangers.
So one of my goals for
today is to help us zero in
on the nature of Eric's Cautionary Tale.
Okay, so in the big picture,
what was Eric's key message yesterday?
Well, I think it was that
causal inferences in complex
nonlinear systems is more
difficult than we wish it was.
And it's certainly more difficult
than is convenient for us in policymaking.
And when we are engaged in it,
we're vulnerable to mistakes.
And this has been shown
in climate science and in epidemiology.
So one of the first
examples that Eric used
was from climate science,
where between 1998 and 2012,
there was this observation of what seemed
to be a hiatus in global warming.
And as Eric described,
scientists were eager to advance
many different hypotheses
about what was causing this.
And as I've done here, we might
visualize these hypotheses
as the more attention grabbing
characters at a party.
But the moral of Eric's
story was that, you know,
it's not always the attention grabbing
like policies that are
the correct ones, right?
And in the case of this observed
hiatus and global warning,
the best explanation was
actually a discreet character,
ordinary internal variability.
So during COVID-19 many
scientists have turned
to the question of which
population level interventions
have been effective in
curbing transmission.
And I took the upshot of
Eric's talk to be that
there's no good evidence
right now that any of these
have been effective and we
don't know how effective
if they have been, right?
So once again, the observed differences
could be the result of
this discreet character.
- Right.
Stephanie, I just want to do, and this,
one of the clarification here
for boom, both you and Eric.
And Eric this is, you know,
other than complete lockdown, right?
So that was clear.
Would you agree that the,
what both of you agree that
complete lockdown prevented
transmission, right?
- I'm going to tell you my interpretation
was that has not been shown well.
- Okay, great, thanks.
I just wanted to in slack there.
We don't come to that question.
I want to make you.
- Okay, and I think I have a little quote
from a paper that does
go into depth about that.
And we can definitely bring
that up in the discussion.
I certainly did not read,
Eric's talk as being, you know,
that that even that has been shown.
But Eric's talk gives us this
chance to go through some of
the challenges that come up
in addressing these types of
questions broadly, right?
So very often in
population health research,
the questions don't lend
themselves to randomization.
They don't lend themselves
to randomized study designs
and that's either because
they're not ethical
or just because they're not feasible.
So we need another way to
control for confounding.
If we're trying to do causal inference.
Now one big class of techniques
basically tries to exploit
some source of arbitrary variation
in who gets the treatment
and who doesn't.
Sort of like across jurisdictions
across different regions and times.
So Eric focused on two
such methods yesterday.
The first being the difference
in differences method
and the second being synthetic control.
So with the DID methods,
basically we're trying to identify
sort of a natural treatment
group, natural control group,
like a place that
implemented a mask policy
and one that didn't.
And then, you know, we're
trying to compare them
in terms of the change in the outcome
before and after the
intervention was implemented.
And then with synthetic control methods.
The focus is similar,
but instead of using one
or two specific real world control groups,
there's a data-driven method
for stitching together,
numerous control groups
into one in a synthetic way.
So basically identifying
multiple control units
that the analyst thinks, you know,
had similar characteristics,
had a similar outcome trajectory prior
to the intervention, similar
to the treatment group,
and then doing a weighted average.
So manage of the difference
in differences method
is that in theory, it's able
to account for confounding
between treatment and control,
as long as con founders
are fixed over time.
But the flip side is that you
have to be able to assume that
there's no sudden changes in confounders.
So as Eric explained,
this is called the
parallel trends assumption.
And it basically means that
we have to assume that,
you know, without the
intervention, the outcomes
for the treated and the
control groups, you know, would
have been following parallel
to a trajectory over time.
Now the synthetic control, you know,
some reason I suddenly can't advance guy.
Do you know why that would
be I suddenly can't advance?
Oh, I think I may because someone
going in the waiting room.
Any suggestion?
- And I admitted that person let's see.
Okay, maybe try now.
- Yeah, okay, now I'm good.
- That's okay.
- Okay, so synthetic control
have several requirements.
I'm not going to go through them.
They're all detailed in the Abadie article
that Eric circulated.
But the point that Eric was
emphasizing yesterday was that
among the requirements,
there are two in particular
that are sort of
intention with each other.
So first of all,
there needs to be appropriate
comparators available.
So to add into this synthetic donor pool,
there need to be available
competitors that are, you know,
they have similar attributes
to the treatment group.
Now, second of all, there
can't be interference
in the sense of spill over
effects of the intervention.
So there can't be sort of a phenomenon
where people are watching
and they're seeing
that the intervention
is happening elsewhere,
and they're sort of taking it
upon themselves to do it too.
So yesterday Eric put
up a quote from Abadie
and I'll do the same here.
So viewers can maybe pause the
video and read this quote for
a good explanation summary
of this tension we're talking about.
Okay, so in a nutshell,
I think Eric was emphasizing
yesterday that methods
for causal inference have requirements.
And it's risky business to be pretending
that we satisfy those
requirements when we don't.
So that was the takeaway, I think.
And I think we might
understand this in terms
of epistemic limitations,
which is a big picture problem
in population health research.
And I want to connect this
to an article from last year
from a group led by Math Bay.
This was a review of methods
that are commonly used
in population health research,
and they clustered them
into two main strategies.
So these are these
instrument based approaches,
like the ones that Eric was
talking about yesterday.
And then there's the methods
that are known as confounder
control approaches.
And their conclusion was
ultimately that, you know,
all of these methods rely
in one way or another
on some unverifiable assumptions.
And further to that there
are trade-offs involved
in choosing what method to use.
And ultimately having different
lines of evidence from
different study designs is
probably the best that we can do.
They also made another note,
which I think is important,
which is that in their experience,
researchers in population health,
they tend to rely on one
or the other method, right?
And there's often a lack of understanding
of the other method, right?
Whatever method one does not specialize,
there's often a lack of
familiarity with how it works.
And this can be problematic
because to really interpret
the evidence well in population health,
one needs to understand the
trade-offs that are inherent
in the different methods.
Okay, so there's
limitations in our methods
but there are also limitations
in our capacities, right?
And I want to connect this to a paper
that I think is relevant.
I know it's on Eric's radar.
So this is a critique
that came out of a model
that was focusing on the efficacy
of different COVID interventions
or, you know, NPI, right?
And, you know, these authors, right?
You know, we conclude that
the model is in effect too
flexible, and therefore allows the data
to be explained in various ways.
And this has led the authors
to go beyond the data
in reporting that particular interventions
are especially effective.
And they say this kind of error,
mistaking assumptions
for conclusions is easy
to make and not especially easy to catch.
So that's a point I want
to put on the table.
Okay, so moving on to
the so now what segment,
I think there are a number
of different directions
that we could take this conversation.
And that includes ideas
like how can we overcome
these limitations?
But instead of doing that
today, I want to steer
towards some normative
questions because I think
they're relate to a number of
themes that we see coming out
in Eric's recent work, and
particularly the three papers
that he circulated in advance of the talk.
So on the bottom of the
screen here, I've put those
sort of truncated titles
of those three papers.
And I just want to
distill a few key messages
from all of those papers.
So first of all, scientific
models, broadly construed.
They're not sort of
truth apt things, right?
They're evaluated in terms
of adequacy for purpose.
And this emphasizes that modeling
is a value-laden activity,
both because purposes are evaluated
and so our notions of adequacy,
so there's a corresponding risk there.
And that's the risk
that modeling decisions,
that come up in the modeling
process and ultimately
models themselves are going
to be inadequate for purpose.
Now, Eric and I call this
representational risk.
And we distinguished
it from inductive risk,
which we take to be the risk
of endorsing a false fact.
So the argument there is
that there's an advantage
to understanding those risks as different,
even though we might want to
draw connections between them.
And even though they both
give us insight into the role
of values and modeling
and values in science.
Okay, so third Eric has argued
alongside some coauthors
that in certain contexts,
our epistemic standards
should actually be quite high.
So for example, when it comes
to restricting civil liberties
it might be acceptable to
do this just on the basis
of precautionary reasoning
for a certain amount of time.
But after a certain point,
this ceases to be acceptable.
And in the long run,
governments are only
justified in restricting civil
liberties on the basis of
good scientific evidence.
So not just, you know, the
best available evidence,
but good scientific evidence,
and also on a careful
and transparent, you know,
cost effectiveness analysis,
which of course is another
normative enterprise.
And then the last point, you know,
in the cost of learning
paper that he circulated,
Eric offers up a framework
to help us think about
the expected net benefits of research.
And this is taking into
consideration that, you know,
monetary costs of research are
not the only relevant costs.
So Eric uses the term on
goody and costs to describe
sort of non-monetary costs of research.
And he's given us some reasons
to think that under some
conditions research could have
a negative expected utility.
So two specific examples UnGoodian costs
that I think are relevant for today.
The first is the
possibility that the results
of research might be taken
as being stronger evidence
than we think is right.
And so basically if we think
that decision-makers are going
to effectively misinterpret the evidence,
then research could have a
negative expected utility for us.
And further to that,
another UnGoodian cost
might be something like
negative externalities.
So for example, maybe
research has been a signal
or something that we
don't want it to signal.
And if that's the case, again,
maybe research could have a
negative expected utility.
I think I'm going to have my same slide
advancing problem folks.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, so now that we know these
terms, that you're abuses,
I just want to sort of riff
off of them and present an
imaginary scenario to
get us thinking about
some of these normative questions.
Okay, so first for the sake of argument,
let's just imagine a model.
Where we all know that the requirements
for causal inference are not met.
So the model is not adequate
for causal inference.
Now, interestingly,
it seems like one way to
evade representational risk
is to just say that the model
has a different purpose.
So I'm thinking of something
a bit analogous to something
that we've seen in COVID
modeling, which is to basically
say, we know, well, the
model wasn't for prediction,
it was for conditional projection.
So then if a model said
something like, you know,
under conditions, A, B, C,
we see X number of infections
or X number of deaths,
but then those conditions don't
materialize those outcomes
don't materialize in the world.
There seems to be no grounds
upon which we can object.
So when it comes to
models that don't satisfy
the requirements for causal inference.
I think maybe we can imagine something
or more than one thing that
would be analogous to that.
So for me, a few distinct possibilities,
come to mind if we go ahead
and we build this model.
So first the model gets
genuinely misinterpreted.
It gets misinterpreted in good faith,
maybe by policy makers or
scientists from another discipline
who thinks that causal
inference is what it's for.
And they use it for that.
Second option, maybe the model gets used
as a rhetorical device.
So no one actually thinks the model
can support causal inference,
but doing it anyway,
allows people to advance
their own preferred policies.
And so they use the model to this end.
And then third,
we might imagine that the
model just goes unused.
So in other words, everyone
recognizes the models,
not for causal inference, causal inference
is what they want and
so they just move on.
So I think at the very least,
there's probably some waste
of money involved there,
but there might be some
negative externalities too.
So maybe in terms of what
we signal to the public.
And then finally, you know,
since we're imagining this,
I think we need to imagine
a few contextual factors
that are probably relevant.
So the first that comes
to my mind would be
the degree of that systemic capacity.
So to what degree is
it possible to know all
of the epistemically relevant
elements of this model?
Maybe that degree of epistemic opacity
would change the picture
for us in some way.
Second, to what extent are
various agents directly engaging
with the model and doing
their own assessments
of adequacy for purpose?
Because it seems like in many contexts,
it's actually a relatively
small number of people who are
really looking under the hood
of the model at a relatively
large number of people
who are just relying on epistemic trust.
And in fact, it seems to be a
standard feature of current,
you know, epistemically
distributed research
and policy-making context.
Now three, assuming that this
is a policy oriented model,
to what extent do people agree
or disagree about what counts
as a benefit?
So this seems relevant,
particularly in contexts,
you know, like nurse mandates,
it seems like people deeply
disagree about what should be
counted as a cost and what
should be counted as a benefit
when it comes to wearing masks.
So for example, if mask
wearing affords me a level of
perceived comfort, does that
make it on the ledger or not.
Beyond that there seems
to be some disagreement
about what price we should be prepared
to pay for what level of benefit.
So even for example, let's
say we had perfect knowledge
that masks cause a 5%
reduction in COVID infections.
Would that mean that we should
implement a mask policy?
So it seems like there's at least
not good agreement there or
not good evidence of agreement.
Finally, I think we should
just get it on the table that,
you know, again,
people do say we need complimentary
evidence from different
study designs to support
robust causal inferences.
So maybe there are some of us
who would carve out a role for
models that they don't allow
causal inference themselves,
but maybe in some way they
would help us reason things out,
down the road maybe,
or possibly in combination
with something else.
Okay, so this leads me to pose
Eric a few direct questions
and maybe he can pick, you
know, which ones interest him.
So first, you know what I'd like to know,
if you think it's legitimate
to assign a causal model,
a different purpose to
evade representational risk.
Also, do you think that there
are conditions under which,
you know, models of complex linear systems
would maybe have a
negative expected utility?
Finally, sort of a two-part
question, you know,
can we do a better job of
articulating epistemic standards
in modeling for causal inference?
And then what about at
the systemic standards
in the policy making context?
So on the latter points,
I am thinking about a couple
of things in particular.
I'm wondering, you know,
do we need to specify the
model purpose in advance?
Does it need to be done in a
particular level of detail?
Do we need to spell out
what are legitimate purposes for models?
And do we need to set
standards around who should be
involved in determining
whether a model is adequate for purpose?
So those are just some ideas
to get the ball rolling.
These are the references that I mentioned,
if anyone would like them and
I will toss it over to Eric.
- Thank you so much, Stephanie,
for these wonderful comments.
Eric please.
- Slide again.
- Oh yeah, I guess I have
to press share screen again.
Is that convenient for everyone?
- Right.
- Is there any disadvantage
to my being the one that shares it again?
- Okay, so yeah.
So the first question, I think it's tricky
because I think when you
do something like that
so in other words, the idea
is like, could I take model
that, you know, looks like
it's job is to, you know,
attribute causes us to something.
But there's not adequate for that.
And I mitigate the damage
of that by being clear
that this is not what the model is for.
One thing this makes me think I'm just
maybe I'll back up to climate.
So in climate science, there's a kind
of long standing history of
these things called the RCPs
the representative carbon pathways.
I think what it stands for,
like in my head that round.
And there's RCP 4.5 and
RCP 6.5 and RCP 8.5.
And pretty clearly these
pathways were picked, you know,
way back, I think in maybe the early 90s
maybe that far ago, I'm not sure.
But there was the idea that RCP 4.5 was
often called business as usual.
And what it is, right?
It's all, it's just a project.
It's just a graph of
carbon in the atmosphere
from, you know, the present
until the end of the 21st century.
And it's pretty standard
for, you know, climate models
to run projections on
these RCPs and show you,
this is how hot the world
is going to be for RCP 4.5.
So I'm not the world's going
to be RCP 6.5, et cetera.
Okay, so some people have sort of started
to complain a little bit
about the fact that RCP 8.5
is still often in the
toolkit, even though it looks.
Even though it's not, sorry, what.
I'm getting a right.
- Could I just request everyone else
to mute their microphones, please?
That might help.
- I'm struggling to mute mine
'cause I'm stuck on share.
- I don't think you're the problem.
- Really weird, I'm not one, okay.
- I don't know maybe not anyway.
Good, so there's been
some people wondering
why are we still doing, you know,
why are we still doing 8.5,
given that it certainly seems
as though the world has
made enough progress,
that 8.5 doesn't really
look like it's in the cards.
So in other words, you
know, we haven't had
the massive increasing in
carbon output that, you know,
maybe people worried
would happen in the 90s
and that's represented in RCP 8.5.
And of course it's, you
know, a perfectly okay thing.
And, you know, a lot of people
say that they say, look,
these are just pathways.
These are just storylines.
You know, 8.5 is just a
story that we're not saying,
there's no indication here that this is
what's going to happen,
these are not predictions.
These are just projections.
This is just like, if we were to do 8.5,
this is what the world would like.
I think there's, you know,
that there's, you know,
of all the things that you
get in the climate to be,
I think that's one where there's actually
some pretty honest debate
that we had about that, right?
Why, you know, how confident are we to be,
that when we put things like
that into the public domain
for consumption that people
will understand this, right?
That 8.5 doesn't really look
like it's on the table anymore.
To what extent or should we be worried
that they're going to
think, look this is this,
we know that some
vaguely in our, you know,
in the back of our heads 8.5
is so-called business as usual.
So when I see the projection on the graph
that's being circulated by
various climate scientists,
various labs, why not say
why isn't it reasonable for me to think
that that highest curve is
what I will expect the world
to behave like if we don't,
you know, make major changes.
So, you know, that's a
tough question, right?
I think when you're putting a
model out there and, you know,
handing to policymakers, not
just handing policymakers
would play it out there
for public consumption
as a way of, you know, and
I don't think it's stretched
to suggest that both climate scientists
and public health experts
over the last year have been,
you know, trying to
influence public perceptions
of what ought to be done.
I think there are interesting
questions there about what,
you know, whether it's legitimate
to put a model out there
that looks like it's doing A,
but in the fine print, right?
It's like, well, actually, if
we're not actually claiming
that we're making causal inferences here,
we're not actually claming anymore
that this is business as
usual, et cetera, et cetera.
You know, I do think there's
legitimate worries there
that you're now drifting
from your job as someone
who I take it, you know, the
standard line is your job
as an academic expert is to
provide us with, you know,
the best information that we can get.
Your job is not necessarily
right to make a determination
about what the best thing
to encourage, the best thing
to get people to support our policy,
because what the best thing to
support policy is, oh, yeah.
You know, as we all
know, obviously, right?
A combination of what to believe
and what to value, right?
And so I think there's a
fine line to be walked there
about when, you know,
modeling efforts like that,
where something is a model is
inadequate for some purpose,
the fine print just says,
we're not really using it
for that for that purpose.
But it sure looks like, right?
Sure, it looks like for public consumption
that that's the purpose it's useful for.
I think there are issues
there that, you know, sort of,
that's a possibly sneaky
way of reaching that line
between informing people and
sort of imposing your views
of what the best balance
of cost and benefits is.
Are there conditions under
which models of complex
and our systems have
negative expected utility?
Yeah, I mean, for sure
there could be, right?
I mean, the phrase on goody and costs
that Stephanie mentioned,
it's just me kind of getting
a more formal decision
theoretic framework to a line
of argument that comes from Kitcher.
Kitcher was interested in
the question of, you know,
when is it bad to do
research into the, you know,
natural ability, natural
differences in affiliating
that exists between sexes and races.
And he just mounts the
argument that, you know,
this is generally speaking
research that's going to have
negative expected utility because right.
Simply because, you know, when it looks
like there's evidence
that there's no difference
in abilities, people tend to ignore it.
When it looks like there's evidence
that there is ability that
makes every newspaper,
it gets on, you know, and
every, it blows off everywhere.
And so there's a kind of
much higher probability
of that evidence being misinterpreted
in one direction than the other.
And then there's a much
higher cost of being wrong.
He thinks right on research
and I agree with him that, right?
If there are differences
and you wrongly point out
that there aren't probably
nothing's going to happen anyway.
But if there are differences
and you point out
that there are, you're going to cause
an enormous amount of harm, right?
To people, by finding this out.
So that's the kind of condition
under which like, you know,
and not like evidence gathering practice
can have negative expected utility.
You know, look over the last year,
we have engaged
interventions that have been
enormously costly to a lot
of people in a lot of places.
You know, particularly there's
I think been a phenomenon
of the following kind, right?
Where, you know, public health experts
in developed countries,
particularly let's say
the United States and
the UK have been trying
to influence policy
here and putting forward
certain kinds of models
that showed certain,
you know, benefits to interventions.
And then those interventions
have been tried
in developing countries.
I have in mind particularly
India and South Africa
where those interventions
were both wildly sustainable.
So they had very low likelihood
of actually providing
any benefit in the long run
and had just enormous cost, right?
So we know about these
things, like, you know,
these death marches in India that happened
when migrant workers were
just cut off from their jobs
and their housing and
their transportation.
So, yeah, I do think that
when you engage in inference,
that you kind of know in advance
that you don't really have
good tools for getting reliable answers.
You ought to think hard
about what the positive
possible negative, expect
each of you just gathering
the evidence is, so I agree
with Kitcher about that.
Can we do a better job of articulating
epistatic standards modeling
for causal inference?
I mean, I think this is tricky.
And I think one of the
things that makes it
especially tricky is a difference between,
this is going to be a muffle,
the difference between
difference in difference
and synthetic control methods.
I think one of the features
of synthetic control methods
for causal inference is it
looks like a magic trick, right?
But if you read the sort
of foundational papers,
I guess I don't really know
how to pronounce his name,
Abadie, is that funny like that?
I'm not sure is that?
- Abadie.
- Abadie, thank you.
If you read like his
foundational papers on this,
he's quite clear, right?
That doing synthetic control
requires a lot of skill
on the part of the person
making the donor pool
for the synthetic control method.
And then if you don't exercise great care
and choosing a donor pool,
you can show almost anything
causes anything else.
So I think, you know, that
difference in difference method
actually that synthetic control method has
that disadvantage relative
to, I guess, difference
in different method
that it really requires
quite a bit more trust in the modeler.
It's a little bit harder to
look under the hood and see
whether things have been done
in a way that really does eliminate
the likelihood of compounds there.
Yeah, and what about epistatic standards
and evidence of proposal making?
I mean, look, I think
we ought to be having
a lot of conversations about this.
I don't know what the magic
wand is, but I do think that,
you know, a lot of these
with all the reasons
we've been talking about,
a lot of these kinds
of scientific work that
informs policy can very quickly
look like they are evidence
for a policy choice, right?
And I think if you go back and say,
look at my report 90
by the SAGE group in UK
that came out I think
March 19th 2020, right?
This was probably the most
influential scientific
report in the history of the world.
I don't think that's an exaggeration.
It very much reads like,
you know, an advocacy
for a set of policy choices.
And it's I think quite clear
that those policy choices
involved balances of costs
and benefits that for
whom the stakeholders were
literally everybody in the world.
So yeah, I think that
it's important that we,
in some way or other, and I
think we need to be having
a lot of conversations about
how the best way to do this as,
and I don't have the answers,
but in some way or other,
we need to be, I think
thinking about the ways
in which when research
like that has been done.
You know, that process of sort of the ways
in which values are entering
into the scientific inference itself are
in some way or another, you know,
getting at the representative values.
Because I think, you know,
one thing that I've sort
of had the growing feeling of
over the course of the last 14
or 16 or whatever months,
however many months it is now,
is that, you know, a lot of the policies
that we've been advocating
have been really good
for the kinds of people that
do the kind of scientific work
that goes behind the policy making.
I mean, there was the
stuff in science studies
that was quite popular in the 1980s
called interest modeling.
And the idea was like it
was in sociologist science.
The idea was you explain
every episode of the history
of science in terms of like
the scientists just reached
the conclusions that were good for them.
And, you know, the classic case was
like 19th century Victorian
work into eugenics, right?
That was like the typical
example of interest modeling.
And, you know, at the
time I didn't sort of,
wasn't a big fan of that stuff
and in general I'm not necessarily,
I think fan of that way
of thinking about the history
of science in general.
But it's felt pretty strongly
to me over the last year
that that's, you know, that
we have instituted policies
over the last 16 months that
have effectively, you know,
diverted the virus away towards
everybody, but, you know,
upper middle class knowledge workers.
And I don't think that's
a massive coincidence.
So I think that's the money question.
Like Stephanie's last
question on the slide here,
but I don't know what the answer is,
but I definitely think this is
a crucial thing to be talking
about if science is going
to be informing policy is
how do we make sure that the
epistatic standards being used
in that scientific work?
You know, are representing the values
of all the stakeholders because
it's pretty clear to me,
at least that, you know, what we've seen
over the last several months
has not been something
where, you know, the science
has been done in a kind
of cool this passionate
way that just, you know,
being informative so that
then policymakers can,
that's our standard picture, right?
The scientists are
supposed to just give us
the information and then the
policymakers are supposed
to represent the interests
of their stakeholders
and combine those interests
with that knowledge and pick policy.
That first part I don't think played out
that way this year.
So I think it is time.
I think it is, you know,
we need to be having
more and more of that conversation.
Okay, I think I'll let other people jump
into the conversation.
- Thank you so much, Eric
for that detailed sort
of response and engagement with some
of the really important questions
that Stephanie has raised.
So I think I wanted to take
the liberty of sort of opening
up to the floor with a question myself.
And, you know, I think
I wanted to come back
to this idea that both of
you had have touched upon,
which is the purposes of modeling, right.
And clarity about the
purpose of modeling and that,
it's almost that the
purpose of that you are
modeling either to make
predictions for practical reasons,
in terms of resource management,
in the case of COVID,
it was to ensure that,
you know, there are enough
hospital beds in particular
cities and regions.
So that was sort of driving
that kind of resource
availability and
assessment was driving it.
I was curious about
what you both felt about
how do we present the motive for modeling
in a more clear cut, transparent way?
I mean, there are,
of course always going to be
people with agendas who will
want to read into it,
no matter how you state,
what your purpose is,
how clearly you state,
what your purpose is.
But I was wondering if you
both had some thoughts about,
you know, how could we have
a bit more transparency
in at least the motives for,
you know, a particular model
and the presentation of a
model in a particular way.
- Eric, do you want to go first.
- Well, I thought maybe
you take that one first?
- Okay, I do have some
thoughts on this matter,
particularly in health economics,
because very often people will
talk about models and health
economics as being for
the purpose of prediction.
And in fact, one of the
major guideline documents
about health economics modeling
has a line that happens
to get me a little worked
up, which is that ultimately
what matters is that a model reproduces,
what happens in reality.
And I'm only paraphrasing
very slightly, right?
And I think that in a lot of contexts,
we're not going to get there, right?
And Eric, I imagined
that you agree, right?
Because what we're trying to
do is predict a system that
probably defies prediction
really at any meaningful level, right?
Particularly in the
context of, for example,
very often, you know,
particularly in Canada,
we do two clinical trials
to evaluate a new drug.
And then we do simulation
models to try to anticipate
what the cost and the
benefits are going to be
to the health system of
making this drug available to the public.
Now, we all know the limitations
of randomized controlled trials, right?
They're conducted under conditions
that are not like the ones
that exist in the real world.
So to just imagine that you're
going to be able to take that
evidence and put it into a
simulation model and have a good
grip on what's really going to happen.
I don't have a lot of
confidence in that process.
You know, further to
that, I think to be able
to make meaningful predictions, you'd have
to have a way of testing,
whether they can doubt, right?
And we don't really do that, right?
In the Canadian healthcare system,
once they invest in a particular drug,
they don't do rigorous
studies to say, okay, well,
now that we've invested in
it, what has happened, right?
So in my own opinion, I
don't think it's quite right
to say that the purpose of
those models is prediction.
I don't think that's well put.
I think it's better to
say that the purpose
of that model is to
inform decisions, right?
And I think the next step then
is to talk about under what
conditions people are wanting
to make decisions and what
their attitude is to uncertainty.
Because there are some really
important normative questions
that need to be answered there.
And there's the dominant line of thinking
in health economics that
basically says you should just
not mind uncertainty and you should go
with what looks like the best bet,
turning a blind eye to the
uncertainty that you have.
And, you know,
some folks might agree that
that's the best way to do it.
I don't happen to agree, which
I think other scores that
that's actually kind of
a moral judgment, right?
So I think that we need to
actually do a better job of
articulating the purpose of the model,
do a better job of fleshing
out our relevant attitudes,
and then having more public
debate around how we want
to do this, because you
could probably do it in way
more ways than we're ever
even getting on the table.
- Right.
- I just want to add
one quick thing to that,
which is that I just don't
even get the idea that
the purpose of a policy
guiding model is prediction
because after all policy
choices are always choices
between at least two alternatives.
And so just being able to
predict what happens under one
particular policy, choice
is totally uninformative.
I need to know what would
have happened and the other
possible policy choice,
and that's not prediction.
And, you know, I mean, I
had a key debates on that,
you know, sort of well-known,
I get hysterical about the
imperial college model and report
nine and the safe group, and
some people like to point out,
oh, they actually predicted the course
of the epidemic rather
well in certain countries.
Well, yes.
I mean, they predicted it
really well in the countries
that followed their advice
because in their model,
they, you know, vastly
overstated the fatality
of the virus and vastly
overstated the effectiveness
of the parcels that they recommended.
So obviously in places where
people followed exactly their
policy, those canceled out and
their predictions were great.
But the predictions for
let's say, you know,
Sweden or for Florida and
were bad in their predictions
for developing countries were horrible.
And it's just, it's not
just saying, oh, well,
we predicted what was going to
happen in the UK was going to
be well that's totally uninformative.
I want to know when
you're full spectrum of
counterfactual projections
laws, because that's
what informs policy predictions
don't inform policy.
But yeah and then I.
- Yeah, so I think thank you both.
I think that they,
perhaps one way to have seen
these predictions that were
made is simply seeing them
as maps of possibilities.
Maps of possibilities and, you know,
and I think the problem with
narratives public narratives
is that because people
don't really understand
what uncertainty inherent
uncertainty means and what a lack
of knowledge of evolving sort
of the provisional nature
of wheel figuring stuff
out about the virus itself
was hindering us from
really getting a grip.
I think that, you know, what
might've been useful was like,
you know, a map of potential scenarios.
And then discuss policy interventions
in the context of a range
of these projections.
And not as you all said to
fixate on one and say, well,
how can we, but I wanted to come back
because Stephanie brought this up.
You know, a little bit of clarification.
And from your experience expertise,
my impression as a person
who works in a field where,
you know, we don't really do
randomized controlled trials,
but, you know, I sort of follow it
because they are seen as
the gold standard and so on.
And in astronomy, there
are people who aspire
to do randomized control styles
in terms of selecting image,
identification, and classification
and so on and so forth.
But to the technique itself,
isn't it true that the whole
methodology zooms that you have
independent non interleaved
causes and that you can
therefore isolate them if
you have compound causes.
And if you don't know what
all causes are possible,
I mean, our cities are no good, right?
I mean, I was just curious, you know,
what are really seen are,
do people in health in
particular because, you know,
that's where these are
sort of the gold standard.
Are the limitations of these techniques
also being sort of actively studied now.
- I think definitely the
limitations of our CTS
are more and more tended to.
And in particular I think
the language gold standard
is definitely on the way out.
I think there are definitely
people that, you know,
still use that but, and I could
be mixing up my fields here.
I know philosophers of science
do not use that term anymore
and they have good
reasons for not using it.
So there are again, yeah,
like a few assumptions
that we have to go on.
If we're going to regard
our CTS as being extremely,
you know, if we're going to use language
like gold standards,
because we think, you know,
all the con founders
are randomly assigned.
They're not effecting things, right.
And of course you can't really
get ever prove that it could
be the case that there are confines that
you're not measuring and
they weren't randomly,
they didn't happen to balance out, right?
Randomization probably balances it open
it doesn't ascertain it for sure.
But I think the thing
to focus on even more
is about this again,
what is the purpose of the
randomized control trial?
And in what respect does
it not suffice for purposes
that actually we deem
very important, right?
So the RCT is answering a
different question altogether.
It's answering this question.
If, for example, in the context of a drug,
does this drug work
under perfect conditions?
That's the question.
And at some point, the relevance
of that question expires,
and we're not interested in that anymore.
We're interested about
whether it's working for us
in the real world.
And then we really get
into a lot of challenges
because we're into this.
Well, now we're in the
real world and there's
all sorts of crazy stuff going on
and we don't know what
we have to control for.
And it's very different
types of folks who are taking
those drugs and we lose
track of, you know,
are they taking it as prescribed?
Are they interacting maybe and
other things they're taking
at the same time and so
on and so on and so on.
So yeah, I think it really does underscore
that we have to understand
the different purposes,
and as well we have to
understand our limitations.
Because it's true that
once you bump into that
observational study
context, then you're facing
all the problems that, you know, Eric
and I just went through in terms of.
- Yup.
- Well now you don't have
that benefit of at least
randomization seems effective
for maybe balancing out compounds.
Eric.
- Just real quick.
I mean, this just merely
summarizing what Stephanie said.
But look, randomized control is great.
It's a great thing to be able to do,
but it also imposes costs like,
suppose you want to do
a randomized control
on the effectiveness of masks, right?
You could do that.
Let's say, you've got
around certain ethical,
you know, issues on that.
You did it.
What would that look like?
Presumably that would look like,
you'd get a bunch of people,
you'd make some of them
wear masks and, you know,
send them into certain controlled
conditions and then see
how they compare to the people
that didn't wear the masks.
Now you're going to eliminate
a lot of compounds there, right?
You probably eliminate all the compounds,
but you're looking at a very
narrow set of circumstances.
You're not then seeing whether,
you know, you're getting,
you're just determining what
mask use does in this very
narrow constrained set of circumstances
that your trial is taking place.
And she might not be that
informative about what happens
when, you know, people
are expected to wear masks
for eight hour shifts
or children are asked
to wear masks in schools or,
you know, excited, sorry.
You can't possibly do on RCT
in which all of the, you know,
sort of in the wild
phenomenon are being studied.
- Right.
- So observational studies do
have a number of advantages
over RCTs because they do
take place in the wild.
But of course, then they
have all their compounds,
et cetera, et cetera.
So there's no magic bullet.
- Right, and I think that, as you said
in this kind of mask study
example that you just gave.
I mean, the idea that
you are marginalizing
over all other variables,
even in controlled study
is clearly observed because
two different people
with different genetic physiological,
underlying proclivities
conditions are going
to react differently to
the same level of exposure
or lack there off, right?
And so we know that
already, we know that about
all our bodies, that there
isn't one metric that can
represent any kind of risk X
because the marginalization
over all other variables
just doesn't work.
I mean, it really doesn't work.
I think we should move on to
the questions that I would like
to first see the floor to sort
of two questions from Chris
who has been engaging
with us offline as well.
And so he says that he has
two questions that are similar
to the third question
that Stephanie raised.
Which first that policymakers are faced
with a comparative assessment.
How do we compare models with
other sources of evidence
regarding the effects
of policy interventions?
They could still be the best
of a very bad lot of possibilities.
Second looking forward,
how could we do better
at drawing these kinds
of causal inferences?
Are there different kinds
of data that public health
agencies should be gathering for example?
- So I'll start with the sec.
Yeah, I'll start with the second question,
because I think that's a little easier.
So to the second question,
I think there are two things
that I've been sort of
pressing for over the last several months.
One is I don't think that we,
I think we did too much changing our mind
about the received wisdom over
the course of this pandemic.
There were, you know, doing
a number of, you know,
sort of standard procedures
in the CDC for doing things.
And they said things like,
you know, don't close schools
for more than six weeks,
you know, et cetera.
And we very quickly
decided in this pandemic,
I think in part, because we
were watching what looked like
we thought we knew it
was going on in China,
we thought like this is so different.
We need to just rip up a playbook
and we need to just be making
all these wild inferences on
the fly and guiding policy with.
And I don't think that was super wise.
I think, you know, science is done,
good science is done slowly.
And it's done, you know,
with peer criticism
and it's done with
stakeholders having a voice.
It's so that was part of it.
And then, yeah, I mean,
early on also very early on the pandemic,
I think we were doing a lot
of modeling was very poor
information about what,
you know, the outcome
of the virus was in different
age groups, et cetera.
And that bear that was the element
that was an easy fix, right?
We could have been doing
a lot more, you know,
serology testing to figure out.
Well, you know, how many
people have been infected?
It's kind of a scandal.
I think that I just, you know,
I obsess over this stuff and I
don't really have a good feel
for how many Americans have
been infected with COVID.
I think it's probably
somewhere between 100 million
and 150 million, but that's probably
the uncertainty gap is wider than that.
That's where I put my and already
that's appallingly large.
We just should've done more than that.
We could have known more than that.
We could've been doing
a lot more spot testing,
random spot testing and
doing more cirrhotic testing,
getting a better feel for
how many people have been
affected, which would have given us early
on a much better sense
of what the, you know,
danger of the rash placed
on different age groups,
trying to which my past adopting
quite different policies
with protective schools.
I think in the developed world,
I think our, the way we've
handled schools has been,
you know, pretty appalling.
There was a really good
piece in the New York times
last week that I'll try
to share at some point.
I think everybody should read
just about how scandalous,
the way we've handled
schools in this country
has been over the last year and a half.
So yeah, so that's,
I think that was your
second question, Chris.
Your first question was,
oh right, what do we do
when it's the best out
of a bad group of walls?
I think the sketch to
Stephanie's question about like,
when does research have
negative expected utility?
And I could answer certainly as sometimes.
I think sometimes the best
science out of, you know,
a bad lot might just be
better left, not done,
or at least not paraded around, right?
In a way that suggests it's,
you know, I mean, you know,
we've had a lot of rhetoric
in the last year and a half
about how various policies
are following the science.
I mean, that's really makes
it sound like two things.
One that there's very little
uncertainty in the science,
and that was crazy.
And second that there's like, you know,
some deterministic mapping
from like the outside
of the sciences to like
what the right policies are.
And that's also crazy.
So yeah, I don't know
when you got, you know,
the least bad method
available, what should you do?
I think that's a tough question.
And I think when that happens, you know,
all of the things Stephanie
was talking about.
About public participation
and about, you know, inquiry.
I think the more, you know,
uncertainty you have, the more
you're selecting from, you
know, the least bad model
from the least bad method
from about bad methods,
the more you need to be paying
attention to the fact that
you're in grave danger of
you know, putting forward
both knowledge and
recommendations of policies
that favor some stakeholders over others.
- Thank you.
Stephanie, did you want to add anything?
- I think I've lost lost the
nugget that I would reply to.
So maybe we should move on to the next one
and I'll weigh in on that one.
- Okay, great.
So the next question was
by Sanji Kumar on causal
discovery and the extent to
which it is about the search
for right counterfactuals
and that it is largely a social process.
So the role of mentors, communities,
connections and networks.
So is this social learning
aspect that does not get
sufficiently emphasized as a
way nonlinearity gets factored
in, and this may not be
amenable to modeling at all,
but how, but we do need to acknowledge it.
And what are your thoughts
about how to take that into account?
- I guess I'm not exactly familiar
with what the question is talking about.
Stephanie is that.
- I'm going to take a
stab at replying to that.
And if I'm off the mark, just let me know.
I also I'm unfamiliar with
some of the terms in that
question, but the part
that I think I'm picking up
is really important has to do
with the fact that you do not
have to model every question.
And I think that's exactly right.
And I think that like part
of what really interests me
is having more open
conversations about like,
what is it that we want to
model, like when we talk about
ourselves as a community
and so far as it's possible,
like which questions do which
communities want to approach
with a modeling strategy?
I think it's wrong to be
pretending that every single
question has to be
approached in this fashion.
And it does connect to
what Eric's talking about
in terms of the negative expected utility
of research in certain contexts, right?
So for example, I think
sometimes we find ourselves
facing a problem that it is very new.
It's going to take some
time to figure out,
and maybe we do want to
assign some scientists
the role of slowly figuring that out.
But that doesn't mean that
we don't have to figure out
policies for now for the interim, right?
And I think that it would be
okay in some context to say,
okay, as a community,
what are we going to do?
We don't have good information right now.
Let's acknowledge that.
And let's just think about what
our goals are and see if we
can get on the same page
about what we really want to
achieve and whether we can
come up with strategies to
achieve those goals that
allow us to avail ourselves of
information that we think is
really good quality, okay?
And I'm thinking in the
context of health, like there's
a whole debate about what
health even is, right?
And if we want to achieve
like in COVID extensively,
what people are really worried about
is people's health, right?
Well, there are lots of things
that society drops the ball
on all the time in terms of
failing people's health, right?
But that doesn't mean
they're because we have poor
information about how to
maximize people's health, right?
So without having and don't get me wrong,
I'm not trying to take this too, too far,
but there are simple things
that society wasn't doing prior
to COVID anyway.
And it might've made sense in
some more moral conversations
to say, okay, well we
have a pandemic going on.
What are some strategies
that probably regardless of
uncertainty, we could
feel good about pursuing?
Could we feel good about pursuing
more sick days for people?
I think you could come up
with a conversation that was
really just normative
in nature that said yes,
in this context,
I think we can feel good
about investing in sick days.
Maybe we can good about investing
in strategies to make sure
there's not overcrowding in certain areas.
So those are just some
questions that I would bring up,
like in terms of if we
in some contexts want
to shy away from modeling,
what would replace it?
I think some public
deliberation could go some ways.
- Okay, now, thank you.
I wanted to move on to the next question,
which I'm going to have
to interpret a little bit
and that I think has to
do with how do we build
and construct epistemic trust?
- Yeah, we got a lot of bridges to fix.
I think about epistemic trust.
I think, you know, look, part
of the reason I brought up
some of these somewhat silly
causal inferences yesterday,
things like, you know,
that the motorcycle rally
caused 35% of the cases
in the United States over
the course of two weeks that,
you know, that Trump voting
counties were the ones
where there were the most COVID cases,
et cetera, et cetera, is, I mean,
this is incredibly dead that
people aren't stupid, right?
I mean, you know, people aren't rubes.
People know that the walls
being pulled over their eyes
with stuff like that.
And it's incredibly, I think,
damaging just scientific
trust to engage in that stuff.
And I it's, you know, I,
it was an election year.
People were passionate about
this last election for reasons.
I understand very well,
but it was alarming to me.
I think that people were
willing to sort of throw
a scientific trust under the bus for that.
I don't know what we can do.
I don't know what we can do to repair it.
Stephanie, you have any thoughts?
- Yeah, I mean, I guess
I do, I feel somewhat.
Well, I don't know if
optimistic is the right word,
but I think one of the
strategies to invest in is more
public participation in science.
Of course, this has been said
by many, many, many people,
but I think that it takes
on an additional importance
when it comes to this
really complex modeling
that's going on.
I happen to work in
more than one initiative
that this is the goal, right?
Is talking to folks
about modeling going on.
And I've met a lot of people who,
the knowledge isn't even there,
that those are techniques
that are being used, right?
So I don't think that's right.
I think that they have a huge
influence on society and that
it's not right for science as
an establishment to sort of
just take off at high speeds and do
a lot of this problem solving,
using these strategies without
making that additional effort
to engage with publics
and say, hey, you know,
we have these strategies that we're using
and this is how they work.
And one of the things that I
think is important is that when
you're given a chance to
explain your methods to lots of
different people at lots of
different levels, you know,
you can actually force yourself
to look at some challenges, right?
Because you can get some tough questions.
Oh, well, how do you show this?
Oh, well actually we can't.
You know, we have to
rely on this assumption
or that assumption.
And those are the types of
conversations that, I mean,
I don't know, I'm not an expert
in what exactly builds
trust, but in speaking
from my own personal perspective,
when I talk to scientists,
I really want to be able to
know that they can tell me
what it is that they're
doing and be honest
about like, where is it?
Are we having to make assumptions?
And what are the gaps and so on.
So I think there's a huge push to be very,
very fast about a lot of things.
And I think some of the solution
is probably down the road
of being a bit slower.
- Yeah, thank you.
So moving on to the next question,
the question is that they want to,
this is Ted Poston and he wants
to pick up again on the role
of knowledge of causal mechanisms
in connection with ethics,
skeptical argument about
inferring causation from the data
exhibited by nonlinear systems.
So he says that he worries
that the argument proves too much.
If it's difficult to infer
causal relationships from data,
as for example, the global
warming hiatus example,
then it's difficult to
infer causal relationships
from climate data of the past 100 years.
The last 100 years is a blip
compared to the millions
of years of climate data.
As climate warming skeptics
argue that our blips over many
years in which the earth warms and cools,
perhaps we find ourselves
in a warming blip,
the reply to this line
stresses that we shouldn't rely
on the data, but our causal knowledge
of the role of CO2 in the atmosphere.
Yet, if that's the correct
response to the global warming
skeptic, then it seems
a defense of masking
and social distancing
can rely on our knowledge
of the causal mechanisms
of how respiratory diseases are spread.
So the general issue here
is whether we are ever in a
position to infer a causal
relationship with data from
nonlinear systems in the short term,
perhaps without the entire
historical data set,
without some background
knowledge of causal mechanisms.
- Good, so let me start with
that climate case, right?
I mean, I think it would
be a mistake to think
that the reason that we think
global warming is happening
is merely seeing that data and knowing
that carbon dioxide is
a heat trapping gas.
Because after all right, heat trapping,
gasses produce feedbacks
in the atmosphere.
Right when the actual warms
that releases more moisture.
Moisture is also heat
trapping, it creates clouds.
Clouds are sometimes heat trapping,
sometimes heat releasing,
it changes the lapse rate
in the atmosphere that is, you know,
it could be heat trapping
or heat releasing.
That's a complicated question.
It melts ice, ice creates albedo.
So there are all these
feedbacks and we have, you know,
I think a pretty,
we have a pretty detailed
understanding of some of that.
We don't just have like, okay,
here's a simple mechanism.
Okay, now, so let's take
the idea that like, well,
what do we know about the mechanism
of like viral transmission?
What's actually pretty complicated, right?
I mean, viral transmission
is fluid dynamics
for healing, right?
And I mean, so, it's not,
you know, some of the people
who were the most expert in this, right?
I mean, this'll be another link I'll share
when I get a chance.
Some of the people who were most expert
on this were warning early on,
you know, these cloth masks.
Don't like, if we are
based on our understanding
of the mechanism, these cloth masks
are not likely to work, right?
Because everybody's worn
one knows immediately
if you wear glasses
and one of these masks,
they fog up your glasses.
So I'm just saying, okay,
we know that we just saying,
we know viruses are things
that get exhaled from the mouth and nose
therefore, can you cover
your mouth and nose.
That's enough knowledge of the
mechanism to then know that,
you know, this is going
to be an effective method.
In fact, a lot of people with
the most expert knowledge
of that were warning early on.
Let's not get people too much, you know,
the thing about masks
of course, was nobody
because it was such a sort of,
you know, mild intervention.
Nobody wanted to be like,
oh no, this is terrible.
Don't do that because,
you know, but I do think
a lot of people were trying to warn,
don't think this is some
kind of magic bullet, right?
Don't don't think that this can substitute
for spending less time in
doors with other people.
And so, you know, the
mechanism there is complicated.
And in fact, right, some of the people
I think were most knowledgeable
about the sort of, you know,
airflow and all that were
kind of raising alarms
about this early on.
And in fact they were in effect trumped
to some extent by some of
these causal inference methods.
So it's a complicated story.
The whole mask thing
is a complicated story.
And I think one of the things
that really complicates it
and I'm sympathetic to
this, I mean, I really am.
You know, one of the that
complicates it was just like,
look, this is such a small ask, right?
We're just asking you to put a piece
of cloth over your mouth.
And so I think that the dynamics
of that were complicated,
but if we're just thinking
about that sort of, you know,
coolly and just
passionately from the point
of you have scientific inference,
I don't think that the sort of, you know,
physical mechanism, reasoning
there was really that good
for thinking that that
cloth masks were effective.
After all, you have to, you know,
be able to breathe through them.
And that just, you know, it's not
like putting a plastic
bag over your head, so.
- Stephanie, did you want to?
- No, I think I'll leave that one to Eric.
I have no expertise in climate science
and I think I would end up
just repeating myself in terms
of, you know, the message that we do have
to have some conversations
about decision-making
under uncertainty, given that
people are just going to have
different takes, you know,
about when we're going
to conclude that something is
one way or the other, right?
Like there are always going
to be folks that are like,
I don't think that, you know,
anything causes global warming
that humans can control, right?
There's always going to
be some of those folks.
So I don't know.
I think I would end up
underlining that again.
- Thank you.
Ty did you want to see if there
are any further questions?
- Sorry, I muted.
Okay.
I think you answered Suda's right?
Lakshmi's question
about complete lockdown.
Yeah, that's order.
Okay and.
- I guess.
- I don't think we had
Jenny Wagner's question
in good way.
Does it help to decide which
subsequent intervention to take
when already having had an intervention
in order to fix some initial conditions
to make evolution models less complex?
That was towards the
beginning of the chat.
Let's see if I can copy it.
- I guess this was about
the purposes of models.
It was relevant to that
set of questions earlier.
- Sure, look, I mean, you
know, there's a simple,
very, very simple like if
you're trying to fix something.
You're supposed to do one
thing at a time, right?
Like I say, you know, your
computer's not working right.
You know, juggle this cord
first, see if that works,
then set back down,
jiggle the other thing.
If you're trying six or seven
different interventions,
all at the same time,
it's going to be hard.
It's going to be hard to pull apart.
You know, which ones are
working and which ones aren't.
That's an added level of
complexity if there are certain
you know, every place is trying
all these different interventions
all at the same time,
it makes it very hard to figure out.
If you think that as a group
they're being effective,
maybe which one is
working, that's extra hard.
I take it maybe that was
the question, I'm not sure.
- So then there's another
question that's just come up,
which is, you know, the
relevance of the concept
of contingency as a way to not evade
the representational risk.
Well, that's an interesting,
what is the relevance of
the concept of contingency?
- Gonna have to say a
little more from me on that.
- Francisco, did you want
to type a little bit more
explaining what you had in mind?
Let me see if they're still
there and might unmute them.
- I'm thinking in the concept.
- Well, let me unmute.
I've asked to unmute them, let's see.
Hi, could you unmute them?
- Yeah, well, I can
only ask him to unmute.
So I'm doing that.
Okay, he's added a few more lines.
- I have to say I don't
quite get the connection.
So he's thinking in the concept
of Stephen jiggles structure theory.
- I'm not thinking of anything brilliant
to say back to that unfortunately.
- So, are there any other questions?
Does anyone else have any other questions?
Please feel free to type
them before we wrap up.
So I think there's one
question that's just come up
that has to do with something
that came up yesterday
in your talk Eric, and
it's about Abadi's dilemma
as it arose in Jaina.
I took it that one of
the horns was the worry
that if you are comparing
Jaina to places similar enough
to Jaina to make for good comparisons,
then they may also be influenced
by mask mandates and Jaina.
My question is, can this lead to mistakes
in either direction or
only underestimation
of the effects of mask mandates?
- Well, I'll just tell you
what I think typically happened, right?
And you can see this in
spades in the South Dakota
in the motorcycle rally case.
So what, you know, what they
did in a motorcycle rally case,
they said, "Oh, well, we want to be,
when we pick our control for South Dakota,
we're not gonna use any neighboring states
because that might,
you know, involve bleed
over from people leaving
on their motorcycles.
And so they went with,
you know, far away states
and that gave them like a lot
of flexibility if you love.
I think trying to piece this
through since yesterday,
because it's been a while
since I looked at that one,
but they ended up using
quite a bit of Hawaii
and the donor pool for
figuring out what the synthetic
for control for South Dakota was.
Now, obviously, right?
That in that case, what's that going to do
that's going to make it look
like a motorcycle rally,
you know, had a large causal effect?
So I think to some extent rate in a,
when you have those two constraints
or treaties that are on it, right?
One that says, "Go look far a field."
When you go look far field,
it just gives you flexibility, right?
So that if the researcher
is then either not careful
or has an axe to grind, it
just, I think opens a pathway
to either overestimating or
underestimating depending
on how you pick the donor pool.
Does that kinda answer your question?
- [Daniel] It does, it just
makes me wonder helping
to change if you are
going the other direction.
So if you compare it South
Dakota to similar states,
then there'd be a worry
that like you're saying,
maybe they're glazed over, but then that,
it seems to me that
would mostly create risks
of underestimation of the effect.
So if you still found a big effect,
that might be informative.
- Right, it typically, in
my experience, having looked
at a bunch of these
synthetic control methods,
they were all errorred
in the other direction.
So, you know, I imagine
that's probably right.
If you had in your
direction, you'd probably
be risking, underestimating the effect.
And I think that's why I
write over all the ones
that were at least being
accepted for publication.
It was usually like, look, you know,
we're showing straight pronounced
effect of the intervention
and we're doing it by being really careful
to go with far-field.
And of course, as we all
know, like after, you know,
after having watched the
epidemic go for 18 months,
I think it's most people can recognize
that allowing yourself to
look far field geographically,
just, you know, allows you to
construct some bad controls
that could sort of show
anything you want them to show.
If you can use Hawaii as a
comparator for South Dakota,
you know, I think all bets are off.
- Great.
It looks like there are
no further questions.
So I would like to take this
opportunity to say thank you
to both Stephanie and Eric for
this wonderful conversation
and, you know, many, many
(clears throat) complex ideas
that are going to be quite
hard, but very important
to address in what we are really
trying to do with modeling,
be it in climate science
or in health economics.
Thank you both very much for
these wonderful perspectives.
And thanks everyone for attending.
We look forward to seeing you all
at the next convening, the July convening
of our inference
colloquium speaker series.
And our speaker will be
professor Elise Crull
from the CUNY.
So thanks everyone.
Bye, and have a lovely weekend.